on Prime crime
on 9-1-1 call leads to a tangled web of
stories
to solve a man's untimely death most
shotgun wounds are not survivable on the
first shot let alone the second shot
[Music]
hey there everybody I'm Jesse Weber and
welcome to Prime crime this is where we
break down the most high profile and
memorable True Crime cases in early 2020
police are called to what seems like a
typical house fire but what they
discover is that like in many of the
cases we cover things aren't always
exactly what they seem to be
Chad Hensel it's January 2nd 2020 in
Bismarck North Dakota
42 year old Chad Ensel hasn't been heard
from in a couple of days some co-workers
had actually went out there that day saw
Chad's pickup in the driveway knocked on
the door and nobody answered when police
arrive at the home there's nothing out
of the ordinary especially since
officers couldn't really see inside the
house from outside however hours later
another 9-1-1 call comes in this time
it's from a frantic Nikki Sue Ensel
Chad's wife I came out here to check so
I've been in the house it's Smoky I
can't get in the door everything was
black do you want to go on shirts
Nikki went out there on January 2nd
that's when she called 9-1-1 saying that
there had been a fire in the home when
help does arrive unfortunately it's
already too late Chad Ensel is found
dead in the master bedroom of the home
the bedroom that Chad had been found in
had significant fire damage When They
Came Upon Chad's body he was naked and
there was a shotgun not far from him
fast forward to a few days later when an
investigator visits the home with Nikki
is it okay if I go in with you yeah okay
he was in the back bedroom on the master
bedroom from this Memorial
[Music]
while at the Ensel residence with Nikki
Sergeant silbernay glad she had to step
away for a minute to take a phone call
he was told that Chad had been shot
twice with the shotgun there's so many
things that point to this not being a
suicide he had been shot once in the
shoulder and then the second time in the
head most shotgun wounds are not
survivable on the first shot let alone
the second shot also Chad had no
evidence of inhaling smoke into his
lungs
authorities find something else that's
suspicious
found two points of origin of the fire
one was upstairs one was downstairs
there was a propane heater that had been
sitting on the floor in the bedroom it
had been tipped over there was a lot of
evidence of a fire in the furnace and
some debris around the furnace one of
the things that we found was part of
like the cardboard of a pack of Marlboro
cigarettes well neither Chad or Nikki
smoked who would want to kill Chad Ensel
authorities need to make sense of his
death and that's when they sit down with
Nikki in the hope she can provide some
insight into her husband
for these five last six nights a week
sometimes more can you drink anymore
she said he was an alcoholic he drank
all the time and that he was both
physically and verbally abusive
so my Nikki never reported any abuse to
the police
at one point in the interview Sergeant
silbernagel changes course and lays his
cards on the table Sharon's death was
not an accident
cat was killed
Chad was murdered
[Music]
it's not a suicide
that's why I want to find out so why why
was why would that happen to Chad
is Nikki holding something back when we
return this case is about to get a whole
lot more complicated it was kind of
something that caught me off guard that
she was even going to throw something
like that out there
[Music]
Nicki did you have anything to do with
Chad stuff no
listen do you know what they need to do
just after New Year's in 2020
authorities in Bismarck North Dakota are
investigating a possible suicide and
suspected Accidental Fire at the home of
42 year old Chad Ansel when he was found
dead in a back bedroom in the home he
shared with his wife 39 year old Nikki
Sue Ansel however it soon becomes clear
Chad didn't kill himself
investigators hope Nikki can shed some
light on what happened and they're
curious about another man in Nikki's
life
came out
with me when we were watching the videos
and reviewing the videos Nikki did show
up at the house in a white pickup with
an unknown male at the time we didn't
know who that was it was only a little
bit later on that it was actually
determined that that was Earl Howard
were you guys romantically involved or
anything
no
okay so you weren't boyfriend or
girlfriend or anything no I'm married
he's married she said that she ran a
catering business out of her home and
that Earl just happened to order some
sort of food from her business one day
and after that they became friends did
you tell her all about the abuse or
anything like that he saw the original
couple times but could you just said you
know
wish you guys fast to the University of
Maine Green Bay
and Nikki reveals something else that at
the time of Chad's death she wasn't even
living in the home with him prior to
Chad and so being killed Nikki had made
several reports indicating that there
was something wrong with the furnace
because the furnace wasn't working it
was winter time she had told Chad that
she was just going to stay at the hotel
yet it wasn't just where she was staying
that's important but who she was with
Nikki where did you go after you came
there when Shadows had fallen
who's winning oh he's you know super
nice person he thinks that you know I'm
super beautiful and I miss him when he's
not around and you know I can tell I
love him Nikki denies to law enforcement
that they had any type of intimate
relationship but surveillance footage
shows them being at least one point
intimate kissing each other Nikki is not
providing a clear picture of what
happened and that's when investigators
make a change I just at that point had
decided that it's probably time having
me go in there and see if I can
make some Headway out of this this is
George hi
um he's with criminal investigations
yeah I have to vote Zone Chad was in a
bowling league December 30th 2019 Chad
had left
in the early evening to go to the
bowling alley during that time Nikki
came to the residence she initially
denied that she had been out there at
that time until I confronted her I know
you've been talking to him and told him
some things some of that I can tell you
right now is not true tell me what
happened when you guys were out there
it's on video there's several entries
into the home but what's interesting is
that the security cameras are actually
such a privacy mode which is really only
something that Nikki Sue could have done
there was information that she didn't
know we knew such as the
camera system actually recording when
she thought she had disabled the
recording function on it Nikki and Earl
visit the home several times that night
but why
you said that you keep your meds in your
purse
she said that the first time when she
was there with Earl while Chad was at
the bowling alley it was just to get
some things because she wasn't going to
be staying there Chad got home well
before midnight about 1am on December
31st Nikki and Earl went back out to the
residence Chad was there at that point
you guys were there for an hour and 40
minutes
you didn't look for your patches for an
hour and 40 minutes while Chad said
they're drinking she said she couldn't
find her medications so she said she
went back to the hotel then at 6 30 in
the morning she now realized that her
medications would be in the bathroom so
then her and Earl went back out there
and she says that she snuck in to the
house while Chad was sleeping and just
went into the bathroom and got the
medication and then what happened
and then why
um
prior to me ever walking in there she
was lying about everything that she was
saying you feel bad about what happened
don't you what's happened in the chat
I have nothing to do with what happened
but you have a really good idea what
happened or I don't yes you do no I
don't somebody killed Chad Ensel but
Nikki says it wasn't her I might be
straight up with you I think it's in
your best interest to just be honest
with us about what you know could it be
someone else stay with us
[Music]
if you were in our shoes what would you
do no
figure it out how am I supposed to do
that do you want to help us
figure this out I do I don't know what
happened in early 2020 a North Dakota
woman says she came home to find her
house on fire with her husband dead
inside what police come to learn is that
Chad Ensel had actually been shot to
death and the fire was likely an attempt
to cover up the murder
police narrow in on his wife Nikki Sue
Ansel and the relationship she had with
another man Earl Howard officials
believe the pair conspired to kill Chad
together
the more you buy it the more it makes
you look like this monster about what
happened that night however Nikki claims
she doesn't know what happened even
reverting back to investigators original
theory of suicide tell me what went down
that night
[Music]
then Nikki shares something completely
unexpected what happened Nikki
[Music]
yeah
why haven't you told me that okay
what does it look like I would say my
tories
spiked hair no glasses very nice teeth
super nice teeth
let me smell
my crown
she actually tried to draw
a picture of this person and it was
essentially a stick figure with hair I
can't get my hair around this that all
of a sudden you told me there's this new
guy that doesn't make sense to me after
a couple minutes of that she
acknowledged that she had made that all
up
tell me what it is you want to say
she finally admits that it was Earl
Howard that was involved in terms of the
death of her husband while she waited in
the vehicle
the only evidence you have of Earl
Howard actually being the one who pulled
the trigger is Nikki saying that Earl
Howard is the one that pulled the
trigger
[Music]
things
who came back to set the fire
she tried to manipulate the security
system we know that Nikki was at the
residence numerous times around the time
that Chad was killed Nikki really
couldn't keep a straight story at all
when you took everything together it was
pretty clear that Nikki
was very involved in this crime
Nikki suenzel is officially taken into
custody both she and Earl face charges
of conspiracy to commit murder arson and
tampering with evidence a couple days
later she reaches out to investigators
to talk
photographs and I just wanted to begin
with
I won't deal with this anymore
he said the courage to be women
[Music]
what exactly is Earl's role in all of
this up next the final home stretch to
learn the unsettling truth behind the
death of Chad Ensel we don't have time
to sit here and listen to the light
anymore this is your last shot
thank you
[Music]
all I wanted was to get out
I just wanted to leave
2020 Bismarck North Dakota an
investigation into the stage suicide
death of Chad Ensel LED local
authorities to unexpected suspects his
wife Nikki Sue Ensel and her new lover
Earl Howard officials theorize that
Nikki and Earl conspired to kill the 42
year old and set his house on fire Nikki
is arrested while officials begin the
search for Earl after she's taken into
custody she opens up a little bit more
about what she says happened
things
[Music]
we have the cigarette pack down by the
furnace that was the same brand that
Earl smokes and nobody else in the home
smoked who came up with this whole
scenario
they didn't have enough evidence to
actually get that murder charge but they
had plenty of evidence on arson evidence
tampering and then conspiracy to commit
murder Earl is captured at the Canadian
border however unlike Nikki Earl Howard
makes a life-changing Choice Earl did
eventually plead guilty to his charges
so he avoided a trial he got 25 years
he's up for up for Pearl maybe around 20
to 21 years then in September 2022 it
was time for Nikki Sue Ensel to go on
trial for conspiring to kill her husband
and cover up his murder
on the surface it appears that it may be
a suicide but as they looked things were
Landing up the shotgun was a little too
far away from the body
the fact that the propane heater
accidentally set fire to a bed in that
bedroom
was too much of a coincidence the
surveillance footage is probably one of
the strongest parts of this case one of
the things that the video doesn't show
that Nikki had attempted to shut off the
surveillance at certain points why would
someone who lived at that house want to
shut off the video surveillance unless
they were about to do something that
they didn't want someone to see
prosecutors pointed to what they
believed was her motive money my name is
and I am calling
you need a call for renters insurance
she took out a renter's policy and then
she also had a life insurance that she
was the beneficiary of that was for
about six hundred thousand dollars
so the twenty thousand uh in coverage
for personal property
also includes four thousand dollars for
loss of use in case you're displaced
from your home due to a covered funds
such as a fire it's never a good look
for a suspect to take out any type of
insurance policy only days before the
person that you will eventually be
accused of killing is then killed she
immediately made calls upon his death to
try to draw from those life insurance
policies
my husband was in there
you lost your husband dear
[Music]
ensel's attorney highlighted a glaring
deficit in the prosecution's case
what is the big piece missing in this
particular case his name's been
mentioned how many times
but he's invisible the defense harped on
one thing that the jury had not heard
from Earl Howard their position was well
Earl Howard would know everything that
happened Earl Howard pled guilty why is
he not in this courtroom was there any
mention of a plan or an agreement to
[Music]
the case is handed over to the jury and
after two hours of deliberations they
came to a decision as to Nikki suenzel's
Future as to the charge of conspiracy to
commit murder we find the defendant
Nikki Sue Melissa Insel guilty the case
was so strong against Nikki that I would
have actually been surprised had it not
come out that way
the loss of my son Chad is unbearable it
is a wound that will never heal your
actions have forever fractured my family
I decided this day is no longer
a day of you
it is a day about my brother this is the
day we remember him and what a wonderful
person he was
before learning her sentence Nikki Sue
Ansel had some final words your honor I
have been through all kinds of abuse now
my boys have been through it nobody
knows the lies I live every single day
not just with Chad
but with the last of my boys
to me my decision is whether it's life
or life without the possibility of a
cruel anything else would be a brave
Injustice Nikki suenzel was sentenced to
life in prison with the possibility of
parole but have all the questions to
this story been answered unfortunately I
don't think we're ever going to know who
the actual person is that pulled the
trigger and the reason we won't know
that is because there's only three
people that know I personally don't
believe that Nikki Sue was the sole
person who did this I believe that she
was The Mastermind but I actually think
that it was probably Earl
um who who pulled the trigger that
doesn't absolve Nikki Sue of any guilt
she's the one who put this kind of crime
in motion
we may never really know what exactly
happened in that house on that cold
December night and there's Apparently
one person who would like to know what
happened as well Nikki Sue Ansel that's
right in a media interview that aired
only a few months before this recording
she acknowledged that her stories
haven't always aligned but she still
denies her involvement in the crime
we'll see how that goes as her case
currently moves through the appeals
process
that's all we have for you here on Prime
crime everybody thanks so much for
joining us and until next time stay safe